will be about killing yourself for a
glimpse of the afterlife opens with
weird-ass non-sequitur Pompeii imagery
in 1990 this was somewhat of a ringing
endorsement this is post st. Elmo's fire
and Lost Boys but prior to his Las Vegas
Review versions of Batman Man in the
beginning of this movie really like
statues and she Wow bacon is built after
Oliver Platt didn't even get the also
starring credit is the ominous sun
foreboding in its very existence wait is
she Walker just making Lost Boys again
why is this medical facility so darkly
lit hospitals aren't designed with mood
lighting in mind people the cabin here
you got caution tape and caution light
stands all over the place it looks like
someone dug up a bunch of sidewalks and
let that bloom for the fall semester
aren't there better ways to tell the
audience hey this building is mostly
abandoned and they won't get caught here
these items kids were called cassette
tapes man were once the predominant form
of audio recording and sharing believe
it or not let's add scalpel into human
foot to the list of images I don't need
movies to show me I have no interest in
watching you kill yourself movie
character states my concerns with the
movie itself less than 10 minutes in
today's exam will be scaled what the
teacher lady these students were all
just actively carving these bodies up
and now you're suggesting it was all pre
class tinkering are their practice
cadavers and testing cadavers in
separate rooms okay so he was kicked out
of school for a questionable medical
decision why is he rappelling down from
his dorm window in the middle of the day
when you get suspended in college do you
have to sneak away or can you just use
the stairs and a regular car to go home
for the weekend I don't want to die I
beg to differ Keefer at the beginning of
this film you said today was a good day
to die so which is it burned your career
today on a stranger now you're turning
your back on a friend but she couldn't
have been more than six degrees of
separation from Kevin Bacon so was she
really a stranger this vehicle and why
does a goddamn expelled medical student
own it does he think this is mad I mean
I'm petty sometimes but seriously what
the fuck is up with this truck this
might be the stupidest truck ever in a
movie I would say this is creepy but it
appears that Hurley is more interested
in watching himself has sex than he is
the girl he's having sex with or just
loves to look at his back
no wait maybe that's creepier also this
individual scene along with the success
of Basic Instinct what's the pitch for
the movie sliver
timely answering machine message is
timely holy Sh look at the size in
Nelson's place looks like he lives in a
mausoleum and he has a computer in 1990
medical students must make a lot more
money than I realized
or he's going to have to pay back
approximately fifteen million dollars in
student loans when he graduates make
sure you got that hair gel just right
for your near-death experience honestly
these flashing yellow caution lights
outside a gothic building like this only
makes me think of the movie relic anyone
or anything that makes me think about
the movie relic is deserving of since
too many minutes of statue porn I'm
adding 10 sins for the statue point
alone we're doing here way too fucking
late for that kind of question dude also
whatever room in the abandoned building
this is in which they're about to do
pseudoscience the columns are all
members of King Arthur's round table for
some reason is he unsure there's liquid
in that thing or carefully yet casually
squirting out liquid to get the syringe
down to more exact dosage levels and
after this he flicks the syringe to
remove air bubbles as so many of you
tell us is a real thing but before that
he was just squirting out for no reason
god dammit let's get into this main plot
point a little bit here so the idea is
to prove that there is life after death
however the person who goes under is by
themselves and has no witnesses to prove
anything they say afterwards is true and
most of mankind isn't gonna believe a
damn thing you say so you're doing this
for mankind how did you not laugh while
saying this was doing it for himself
alone yet somehow you've wrapped all you
suckers up in his plant why do I
suddenly see you on 16 minutes sandwich
in between Andy Rooney and a super
commercials well because that's the
ultimate conclusion here to what you're
doing
well professionals by professionals you
mean students who have yet to earn a
medical degree then yes professionals
I'm no kill yourself but then come back
to life expert but I feel like these
sensors being stuck to his face or a bit
of cinematic overload oh you'll be dead
and the three of us will go to prison
for murder
bacon ex machina well I totally get
stuck all in the Hurley's current
freakout session it's fair to question
why the hell they even came they knew
exactly what was gonna happen when they
got there Hurley decides to go on guard
with his murder field
Nelson's afterlife is essentially an XTC
video with some synth-pop and a guitar I
mean thank God Kevin Bacon showed up
tonight am i right
20 years before sinister was a movie
Trevor began as hijinks for you film in
the last couple minutes asshole looking
floor you have one job even if you die
and come back to life can you really do
both things inside of a few hours and
then still be in walking through campus
condition he shoved him in a truck and
drove into Chinatown and then they
decided to check his vitals movie
suggested Billy Baldwin is alive only
because one med student CPR kung-fu is
better than another's the lesson here
kids is that even if you're a sexist and
straight up creep in real life your
afterlife will consist of a bunch of
Victoria's Secret models lusting after
you why yes Oliver Platt is wearing
suspenders on top of his sweater vest
thanks for noticing this could be the
conquest of our generation the last
great frontier what's it gonna have to
question both the importance of this
discovery and the ability to accurately
convey to the masses what exactly happen
I mean what the cure for cancer or AIDS
be a better example of the last great
frontier people would actually have
physical proof that it's true came back
from the dead yes let's share knowledge
of our very illegal experiments with
random lunchlady
you're looking for answers there's no
answers here III think you just saw what
you wanted to see Dave would be great at
writing cinemasins
to 10 to 20 poor fraidy-cat Julia
Roberts she keeps losing her turn to die
by being out named that tuned by the
Jackie Kaka guys also the last time you
guys did 130 now you're jumping up to a
total time dead length that is more than
50% longer of a time period his walk
home naturally leads him through dark
alleys late at night and boy howdy if it
isn't the most populated late night
alley in the history of ever
goddamnit Trevor if we were already dead
and had nothing to lose by dying or
perhaps it was because we lived life so
well ruby has time for this burning man
origins yes even with the cycle of Lost
Boys Halloween rager bonfire going on 25
feet away they're still gonna kill one
of their own tonight and try and revive
it this question be damned are you
supposed to be
boner man hmm zooming in on the bridge
of his nose I wonder what that could
holy sudden freaking out what if he
didn't make it back it should be some
Rachel feel like when Keefer went to
Joel Schumacher for Direction he told
him to go ahead and dick it up as far as
he could and then just stick it up some
more
does anyone inventory and keep track of
the school's medical equipment and drug
supply cuz movie sure don't seem to
think so
to 1,000 Joe keep doing bring back that
you even thought to say this is a lot
about your motivation student we're the
footprints of distraction so the kid
could get Nelson from behind that seems
way too elaborate why not just hit him
in the face as soon he's walks in the
door I realize he doesn't want to tell
his modern friends that he harassed a
kid in his youth but not telling them
anything about the thing I saw while I
was dead trying to kill him in the real
world is a huge sin of omission same
goes for Baldwin a book called
euthanasia leaning against a picture
frame is what this movie thinks is
thematic subtlety are they doing this
every night now seems awfully convenient
that manases afterlife takes her exactly
where she wanted to go that glass of
punch is full of confetti you cretin the
fact that it took this long for this to
happen given the setup shown here is
unbelievable Oh maybe we should have
planned all this better so either he
shot himself or someone else shot him
we've yet to learn but this bloody
gunshot home the windshield is only
adding to the questions was he sitting
in the middle of the front seat for some
reason did he shoot himself but do so in
a manner that produced this gunshot wall
the filmmakers don't care they just want
you to feel the emotion and probably you
did all right good on them but logic is
long gone in Springville I've been
haunted by these images of women that I
videotape without them knowing not sure
haunted is the right word these women
are still alive presumably unless of
course Hurley killed them all which
would Brahmin would make a more
interesting movie than this one we would
definitely have seen less demonic kids
dropping loogies of all members of the
Joe Hurley video library it's creepy
enough you videotape these women without
their knowledge but then you branded
said collection of videos I always
assumed Daniel was the creepiest Baldwin
but William was making a strong case
here pretty sure Dave had a choice no
one forced him into doing this in fact
they were all willingly bidding on how
long they would go under also could the
screenwriter not get a little more
creative with the sins both Nelson and
Dave are being haunted by kids they
picked on in grade school Nelson is
really hoping that the ghosts are turned
away by the power of a dead bolt also he
locks all his doors but does not arm
himself with any kind of weapon
considering the trevor beat him up once
with fists and once with a hockey stick
it's insane this guy isn't holding a gun
right now
movie is really really sorry for
bullying you back in grade school Joe
climbs the stairs of the ghost shoot
them and film them past
also while obviously Hurley is a
despicable human being these women
actually fell for these lines only Kevin
Bacon is smart enough to try and contact
his past life tormentor in the present
day to try and make amends and that's
just goofy why is man is working on her
cadaver by herself while everyone else
has a partner I have a little girl let's
go for me how you doing I'm fine for
somebody who keeps running into her
father who's been dead for 20 years so
is that a yes on the okay can we have
sex now I've told me gentlemen I'll give
keeper this he really went for it
doesn't make it a particularly
interesting or good performance but he
gave it as all the dogs bark at Nelson
this is a graveyard Thank You captain
obvious
this is where Billy lives if Nelson knew
the kid was dead then why not just tell
her Leanne Stickle earlier also why is
Hurley soon from people who are still
alive while Nelson and Manas have to
deal with situations where the person in
question is dead this script sucks is
the only answer I can come up with Billy
Mahoney died 17 years ago and whether he
actually is or not Nelson fish
responsible according to the tombstone
Nelson Hurley and stucco came across
Billy died in 1976 which means 17 years
later would put this movies timeline in
1993 even though the movie was released
in 1990 and presumably takes place in
present time also while Dave's opinion
that as a kid you shouldn't be held
responsible for your actions might hold
up for his and especially manases
predicament Nelson is 100% responsible
you threw a rock at a kid knocking him
out of a tree and killing him that's it
Billy just wanted to knock Nelson out of
the tree I didn't beat him in the subway
knocking him over the head with a hockey
stick or slicing him across the face
with a screwdriver suffice and how did
Billy know that Nelson would eventually
figure out that he needed to go back
under to make peace with him he could
have let better clues is all I'm saying
only Trevor forgives Semana stave and
Nelson have all found peace with their
past sins or at least one step but I
guess earliest
hereby want Jerry Seinfeld to remove my
life support feeding machine lung blower
etc etc etc
I got some chilled d5w in the cooler
it's Miller time
[Music]
sometimes I doubt your commitment to
Sparkle
Gandhi oh the passion - but you couldn't
get a porn star off your hairpiece looks
like something that was killed crossing
the highway I don't know whether to
Coleman or scrape it off with a shovel
and buried alive I never said I had
binoculars I have a highly magnified
telescopic image of you